there are hundreds of small farming
villages in ukraine that were invaded
and occupied by the russians
this is the story of just one of them
on the road north out of kiev
alexander has hidden the clothes he was
wearing on the night the russians came
for him he's keeping them safe as
evidence of war crimes
he shows us the blood on his tracksuit
bottoms where a nail was hammered into
his knee
and the fabric that was used to tie his
hands behind his back
he has scars on his face where he was
burnt with cigarettes
he doesn't want us to identify him
because he's scared that the russians
might return
tourists
there's no beer a soldier put my hands
on the table and hit them three times
with the butt of a machine gun my arm
was badly bent and broken alexander
tells us
he kept on saying you're a nazi you're a
nazi they hit me so hard on my head i
heard something crack there was so much
blood on the floor that a soldier
slipped in it my nose was broken then
they threatened to cut my tendons and
kill me
nearby is the house where they tortured
alexander and others in a room up on the
first floor he tells us
it is just a few doors down from the
village school
well what's left of it now
this became the main russian base when
they occupied the village
every single room has evidence of
rampant depravity
as a final insult they smeared their own
excrement on the walls
and then fire bomb the place as they
retreated
[Music]
the russian soldiers went house to house
through the village marking front gates
if people lived inside
like everyone julia vasilenko got a
knock on the door she's married to the
village policeman vyacheslav
he was taken away that day and he hasn't
been seen since
foreign
these are the stories of just one
ukrainian village
men women and children
whose lives and futures have been
irrevocably changed and damaged during a
hundred days of war
aleister bunkel sky news in ukraine